dabei ist luca und meine lieben freunde
soeben war ich duschen welcher mensch
sagt soeben luca badoer auf jeden fall
gerade duschen und das ist der grund
warum meine haare noch nass sind und ich
bereue es allerdings da ich jetzt wieder
komplett schwitzen werde weil wir
triangulation
mich dieser kommentar und da eines
meiner letzten videos geschrieben und es
sollen sehr krasses spiel sein wir
starten jetzt einfach mal ein neues
spielen und werden dann wahrscheinlich
direkt trab
[Applaus]
sind wir das
oder
juli
wie das sind wir
der blaue fall
und wir sind jetzt auf dem mond
okay okay
das ist level 1 h
was soll daran schwer sein wo ich hasse
ja spiele wo sonne hintergrundmusik mit
dem start ist also ich habe jetzt die
musik ausgemacht weil wenn ich sie an
machen würde wird sich so anhören
und ich bin ganz ehrlich dafür habe ich
heute morgen noch keinen nerv wir haben
dadurch jetzt allerdings auch keine
sounds von diesem komischen raumschiff
ding hier deswegen freut euch einfach an
mit meiner hintergrundmusik hier und
kein raumschiff zu
ok
also ich bin jetzt echt den steuert sich
statt sich wie
ganze ding hier steuert sich wie so ein
alter vw lupo
ganz langsam
ich glaube das ist auch die beste
medizin einfach langsam vorgehen zack
chillen ich komme schon um die kurve
zeigt einlenken bamm bamm bamm bamm
ich werde nie wieder stellen wir euch
einfach langsam vorgehen werde jetzt
[Musik]
bei diesem spiel was wir letztens
gespielt haben was ja angeblich das
schwierigste spiel der welt war
zumindest noch irgendwie rückwärts gehen
oder so aber das kann ich ja gar nicht
kann nun
[Musik]
einlenken früher als man denkt sagt und
jetzt hier perfekt rohr
gegenlenken tag perfekt um die kur wird
sagt der ist super super da komme ich
dann vorbei da komme ich perfekt an
vorbei ich glaube ich muss sogar gar
kein gas mehr geben ich komme einfach
ins ziel
es gibt dinge die sich bewegen ich habe
keinen plan
keine ahnung wie ich da irgendwie dran
vorbei kommen soll allerdings sieht das
sehr sehr dass sie
verschmerzt aus ich muss auf jeden fall
mit ich dadurch weil unten lang macht
keinen sinn zack zack wieder hier
gegenlenken zack zack hier vorne
gegenlenken sagt hier
ich hasse sie person die mit der spieler
fordert
[Musik]
hna online
dort war das stark ich bin drin ich bin
drin ich habe keine ahnung was ist ihr
vorteil ist ob man davon weggedrückt
wird oder auch das macht einfach die
perfekte
mein tisch tut mir echt leid das macht
einfach nur diese türe auf so dass man
dann dadurch kann und ich glaube auch
dass ich ganz easy bremsen kann ich mich
beispielsweise um nach perfektion ich
wollte sagen ich kann ganz easy bremsen
indem ich einfach gas gebe dann drehe
ich mich um und dann streichen
wow
ich halte jetzt mein mund
und macht das jetzt
[Musik]
einfach ging
einfach der king hier haben wir nun ein
etwas schwierigeres komplizierteres
level mit einem duell lockt also wir
müssen erstmal nach hinten das ist
allerdings ganz entspannt so zac und
jetzt bremsen jetzt nach vorne jetzt
wieder hier vorne abbremsen denn nun
können wir jetzt einfach hier vorne
runter sagt sagt so sollten auf jeden
fall ankommen und jetzt so wieder nach
oben denn dann können wir hier warum
jetzt allerdings wieder hier gegenlenken
so so so so so perfekt und jetzt leiden
wir ins ziel ich hab es raus ich hab es
raus ich werde nie wieder sterben
[Musik]
tank hat direkt direkt weiter geschafft
ich sag's euch das ist mein dass das ist
mein spiel ihr hättet mir das nicht
empfehlen dürfen ich bin gemacht für
solche spiele wissen die wenigsten
[Musik]
ich weiß ich abwarten muss bis sich das
ding mal komplett im kreis gedreht hat
hierbei der rechten komischen kreise
bewegung hier allerdings wird es sich ja
ok ich muss abwarten einfach
weiter
ich komme hier nicht lange
das heißt ich muss wahrscheinlich direkt
da oben durch also werde ich versuchen
das ganze einfach hier lang zu machen
denn so sollte ich daher glaube ich auch
durch komme ich bin ja nicht genannt
auch
nicht ganz entspannt erst hier vorne
sich den halbkreis drehen lassen und
jetzt muss ich allerdings gleich direkt
rüber nach da oben also
ich vielleicht gruppen krumbad
sparen sich den kreis drehen lassen
haben wir auch gar keinen stress und
jetzt orientiere ich mich schon mal hier
nach vorne denn ich werde jetzt
direkt hier
perfekt
direkt nichts ich sag euch jetzt
schaffen
ich brauche manchmal ein paar mehr
anläufe ja ich weiß aber
jetzt ist meine zeit gekommen
guckt euch das an
[Musik]
perfekt
einfach nur noch perfekt
jetzt hier unten lang ganz entspannt
ganz entspannt ganz entspannt der typ
hier dreht sich wieder alles easy und
jetzt das
das ist nicht dein ernst
wenn sie vielleicht vorher sagen dass
ich da direkt noch mit rein muss weil er
sich nicht weiter dreht vielleicht so
luca ganz entspannt ganz entspannt wir
haben alle zeit der welt super super
super
diese dumme waren das kann ich beruhigt
ich bot
[Musik]
ok
auch keine chance
mein schatz
das video
geht jetzt erst enden wenn ich sterbe
und
hier wird geschichte geschrieben die
halo wars
nie wieder nie wieder